[Music]
the united kingdom has become a mere
shadow
of the nation that gave us freedom of
speech freedom of the press a host of
other rights that we take for granted
but probably should not take for granted
nobody knows that better than tommy
robinson in may of this year he was
arrested
for attempting to cover the trial of a
sexual grooming gang
in the uk for speaking out loud on the
sidewalk he was
taken to prison with barely any time to
muster a defense he was tried and
sentenced to 13 months in jail
now after more than two months behind
bars in solitary confinement
during which time he was attacked by
journalists in the uk almost nobody
defended him
but tonight he has been released on bail
after winning an appeal tommy robinson
joins us now for his first
and only interview tommy robinson thank
you very much uh for agreeing to talk to
us i know that you've spent the last two
and a half months by yourself in a cell
so you're probably
feeling a little bit uh bewildered to be
out
tell us what it was like for you behind
bars
for me behind bars it the way i was
treated i was taken to a prison with a
with quite a low muslim population what
i'm known for is criticizing islam so
there's been many
planned attempts to murder me and kill
me in this country i was taken to a
prison with a low muslim population of
seven percent where things were
relatively normal i was separated from
other prisoners
but the prison officers made sure they
opened my doors multiple times during
the day
and they took me out to play pool and
snooker with themselves i was then taken
from that prison and transferred
to another prison and i was transferred
to the prison with the largest muslim
population
in the uk for a ccap prison i was then
put on poland solitary confinement where
i spent
two months um not seeing or speaking to
anybody and they used the reason that
i was in danger now they would have had
risk assessments before i went there i
was purposely taken to be put in danger
so that then that reason can be used to
then put me on solitary confinement
and if you think about what has happened
in this case it took a number of hours
to put take me before court prosecute me
unlawfully imprison me
and then it took two months with the
prisons moving me to prevent my legal
access
shortening my legal visits and it took
months before i got the opportunity to
go before a judge
once the judge heard what had happened
in the trial we found so many illegal
and wrongdoings within this kangaroo
corps
that then it took another two weeks
before i was freed
and and to be honest this whole
encounter if you
talk about i i haven't eaten i've lost
nearly nearly 40 pounds
in prison i had one tin of tuna and a
piece of fruit a day
i i was supposed to be in her majesty's
prison service
not guantanamo bay i couldn't open my
windows because i was having excrement
and spit put through them i had i
believe this whole process and tucker
this isn't the first time i'm sorry but
who is putting
extra through your window and spit
through your window
so my my prison cell that i was putting
was on the lower level the ground level
which it didn't have to be
so it's on the ground level so every
prisoner would walk past my cell window
everyone
as they walk out so when my windows were
open though
every prisoner's walking past but the
mosque for the prison was directly
opposite myself
so every time we've had a huge heat
waves i was literally drenched day to
day
and i'd excrement and spit thrown
through through the doors
through my window so in the end i had
completely blocked up windows had to
block up all of my
my cell windows and all of this when i
say
this to a lot of people around the world
this what this current case in the world
has watched it has shocked them
for me this has been nothing new there's
some things i have not spoke about in
the past when in
in 2012 i spent five months on solitary
confinement
in the british prison this goes against
every human right and every law
i spent five months when i come out
i was diagnosed with a form of
post-traumatic stress disorder i've
never spoke about that publicly because
i don't want to insult victim
members of the military who have
witnessed war and try and compare being
locked in a cell in solitary confinement
to that but that my medical records are
fully aware that the authorities are
fully aware of them the government are
fully aware of and the prison service
are fully aware of them
they know what that did to me they know
what i went through after that
they leave but i guess wait let me
interrupt you i
just wanted i just want our viewers to
understand
why this happened to you in the first
place you went to prison in a supposedly
free country for expressing
unfashionable opinions
in public did you with this last round
you've been in jail for two months did
you
hit anybody did you steal anything or
did you say something the government
didn't like
there was a court case going on where 29
people are in court for gang raping
up to 100 young children now i stood
outside the court
and i i spoke and all i done was read a
bbc news article a bbc news article
that is still online now for millions of
people to see
now and i was taken and everyone would
have watched the video they said for a
breach of the piece
they transported me to a police custody
and then my solicitor contacted the
police custody
then they emailed my solicitor which my
sister has this email saying i was being
released
then they took me in a van back to the
court through the back door
they put me up before a judge and media
reports have said that i pled guilty
these are at no point was i even asked
whether i was guilty or not guilty
i was not even told and i still to this
point now have not been told
and do not know what it is i'm deemed to
have done wrong
in a british court of law for a fair
trial for anyone they have to understand
what it is they're being accused of
contempt of court that's all i've been
told what what contempt of court
i i was fully aware outside that court i
made sure to point out that these men
are innocent until proven guilty
i said alleged i was non-confrontational
there is not
the judges and i know the law the judges
have no power to issue reporting
restrictions
on anybody on any information that is
already in the public domain
i was taken and worked away and what
we've seen this week is the highest
judge in
our country has completely condemned
this as flawed
completely criticized that the handling
of this case
the kangaroo court style it was to
imprison me and my biggest concern with
it is
at this time that when this has happened
and so many people i i say thank you to
the middle east foreigner thank you to
congressman gosar a
thank you to ambassador brownback people
thank you to yourself tucker
people who come out because we know that
in in this country anyone who speaks
about islam you can believe him
completely liberal the minute you
mention criticize
islam you are deemed and attacked by
everybody now
and people put their neck on the line
did anyone let me just ask you now did
anyone defend you i mean even if people
disagree with you you would think
some would say he has a right this man
has a right to express his opinions did
anybody defend your right
to say what you think is true everyone
of authority
and every media company in mainstream
media lined up
and lined up to completely do hatchet
jobs
about why i should be in prison and how
i deserve to be in prison
and hume one the worst one i'm reading a
human rights lawyer
a human rights lawyer defending why i
should be in prison
now i'm in prison i'm facing absolute
they know that what they're doing to me
they they know at the time when i was in
prison i i then
they then come and see me in my prison
cell and say police are on their way to
your house
because there's intel there's going to
be acid attacks against your wife
now and then i'm sorry tommy we're
we're out of we're out of time and on
that sad note
i just i i wish you good luck in
recovering from this and on the time
you're going to take off
and i just want our viewers to
understand that this has happened in a
country that we believed was free
and without our vigilance it could
happen here that's not hysteria it's
real
tommy robbie thank you very much